morning from australia
i'm very pleased to join two great
friends of freedom and of australia
prime minister johnson
and president the joint address as you
can see let's listen join our nations in
a next-generation partnership
built on a strong foundation of proven
trust
we have always seen the world through a
similar lens
we have always believed in a world that
favors freedom
that respects human dignity the rule of
law
the independence of sovereign states and
the peaceful fellowship of nations
and while we have always looked to each
other to do what we believe is right we
have never left at each other
always together
never alone
our world is becoming more complex
especially here in our region the
indo-pacific
this affects us all
the future of the indo-pacific
will impact all our futures
to meet these challenges
to help deliver the security and
stability our region needs
we must now take our partnership to a
new level
a partnership that seeks to engage not
to exclude
to contribute not take
and to enable and empower not to control
or coerce
and so friends orcas is born
a new enhanced trilateral security
partnership
between australia the united kingdom and
the united states
orcas
a partnership where our technology our
scientists our industry our defence
forces are all working together to
deliver a safer and more secure region
that ultimately benefits all orcus will
also enhance our contribution to our
growing network of partnerships in the
indo-pacific region anzas
our asean friends
our bilateral strategic partners the
quad
five eyes countries and of course our
deer pacific family
the first major initiative of august
will be to deliver a nuclear-powered
submarine fleet for australia
over the next 18 months we will work
together to seek to determine the best
way forward to achieve this
this will include an intense examination
of what we need to do to exercise our
nuclear stewardship responsibilities
here in australia
we intend to build these submarines in
adelaide australia in close cooperation
with the united kingdom and the united
states
but let me be clear australia is not
seeking to acquire nuclear weapons or
establish a civil nuclear capability
and we will continue to meet all our
nuclear non-proliferation obligations
australia has a long history of defense
cooperation with the united states and
the united kingdom
for more than a century we have stood
together for the course of peace and
freedom
motivated by the beliefs we share
sustained by the bonds of friendship we
have forged
enabled by the sacrifice of those who
have gone before us
and inspired by our shared hope for
those who will follow us
and so today friends
we recommit ourselves to this cause
and a new orcas vision
i'm delighted to join president biden
and uh prime minister morrison to
announce that the united kingdom
australia
and the united states are creating a new
trilateral defense partnership known as
orcas
with the aim of working hand in glove to
preserve security and stability in the
indo-pacific
we're opening a new chapter in our
friendship
and the first task of this partnership
will be to help australia acquire a
fleet of nuclear-powered submarines
emphasizing of course that the
submarines in question will be powered
by nuclear reactors not armed with
nuclear weapons and our work will be
fully in line with our non-proliferation
obligations
this will be one of the most complex and
technically demanding projects in the
world
lasting for decades and requiring the
most advanced technology
it will draw on the expertise that the
uk has acquired over generations dating
back to the launch of the royal navy's
first nuclear submarine
over 60 years ago
and together with the other
opportunities from orcas
creating hundreds of highly skilled jobs
across the united kingdom including in
scotland the north of england
and the midlands taking forward
this government's driving purpose
of leveling up across the whole country
we will have a new opportunity
to reinforce britain's place at the
leading edge of science and technology
strengthening our national expertise
and perhaps most significantly
the uk
australia
and the us
will be joined even more closely
together
reflecting the measure of trust between
us the depth of our friendship
and the enduring strength of our shared
values of freedom
and democracy
only a handful of countries possess
nuclear-powered submarines
and it is a
momentous decision
for any nation to acquire this
formidable capability
and perhaps equally momentous for any
other state to come
to its aid but australia
is one of our oldest friends
a kindred nation
and a fellow democracy and a natural
partner in this enterprise
now the uk will embark on this project
alongside our allies
making the world safer and generating
jobs across our united
kingdom thank you over to you mr
president
thank you boris and
i want to thank
that fellow down under
thank you very much pal appreciate it mr
prime minister
i
am honored today to be joined by
two of america's closest allies
australian united kingdom to launch a
new phase of the trilateral security
cooperation among our countries
as prime minister morrison and prime
minister johnson said i want to thank
you for this partnership
your vision as we embark together on
this strategic mission
although australia
the uk and u.s partnership caucus it
sounds strange with all these acronyms
but it's just a good one
aucus our nations will update and
enhance our shared ability
to take on the threats of the 21st
century
just as we did in the 20th century
together
our nations
and our brave fighting forces have stood
shoulder to shoulder for literally more
than 100 years
through the trench fighting in world war
one
the island hopping in world war ii
during the frigid winters in korea korea
and the scorching heat of the persian
gulf the united states australia and
united kingdom have long been faithful
and capable partners and we're even
closer today
today we're taking another historic step
to deepen and formalize cooperation
among all three of our nations because
we all recognize the imperative of
ensuring peace and stability in the
indo-pacific over the long term
we need to be able to address both the
current strategic environment in the
region and how it may evolve
because the future of each of our
nations and indeed the world depends on
a free and open indo-pacific enduring
and flourishing in the decades ahead
ahead
this uh this is about investing in our
greatest source of strength
our alliances
and updating them and to better meet the
threats of today and tomorrow
it's about connecting america's existing
allies and partners in new ways and
amplifying our ability to collaborate
recognizing there is no reasonable
divide
separating the interests of our atlantic
and pacific partners
indeed
this effort reflects a broader trend of
key european countries
playing an extremely important role in
the indo-pacific france in particular
already has substantial indo-pacific
presence and is a key partner in
alliance strengthening the security and
prosperity of the region
the united states looks forward to
working closely with france and other
key countries as we go forward
and finally
this initiative is about making sure
that each of us has a modern capability
the most modern capabilities we need to
maneuver and defend against rapidly
evolving threats
aucus will bring together our sailors
our scientists
and our industries to maintain and
expand our edge and military
capabilities and critical technologies
such as cyber
artificial intelligence quantum
technologies and undersea domains
now as a key project under august we are
launching
consultations with australia's
acquisition
of conventionally armed nuclear-powered
submarines for its navy conventionally
armed
i want to be exceedingly clear about
this
we're not talking about nuclear-armed
submarines
these are conventionally armed
submarines that are powered by nuclear
reactors
this technology is proven
it's safe
the united states and uk have been
operating nuclear-powered submarines for
decades
i have asked secretary austin of the
department of defense to lead this
effort for the u.s government in close
collaboration with the department of
energy and the department of state
our governments
will now launch an 18-month consultation
period to determine every element of
this program
from workforce to training requirements
to production timelines to safeguards
and non-proliferation measures and to
nuclear stewardship and safety to ensure
full compliance with each of our
nation's commitments under the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty
we'll all undertake this effort in a way
that reflects the long-standing
leadership in global non-proliferation
and rigorous verification standards
in partnership and consultation with the
international atomic energy agency
so i want to thank
the prime minister prime minister
morrison and prime minister johnson
for their friendship but mostly
important for their leadership and
partnership as we undertake this new
phase of our security cooperation
and the united states will also continue
to work with asean and the quad
as was stated earlier
our five treaty allies and other close
partners in the pacific as well as
allies and partners in europe and around
the world to maintain a free and open
indo-pacific
and build a future of peace
opportunity
for all the people of the region
we're joining together our partnerships
are getting stronger this is what we're
about
i want to thank you all and i look
forward to seeing both of you in person
very soon i hope thank you